me satisfacen estos cambios los pedidos
de la oposición que se negaba a reunirse
con boris hasta que se diera esta
reestructuración
bueno yo creo que por el resultado de
asistencia de la reunión que realizó el
presidente con los presidentes de
partido y color representante de los
sectores políticos en el país hubo un de
cierta forma una satisfacción con el
cambio era una demanda que había puesto
la oposición como condición a participar
en cualquier reunión para avanzar en la
continuidad del proceso constituyente y
entiendo que hoy a las 17 horas se
reunieron
obviamente en un primer encuentro que da
pie a un proceso que probablemente va a
demorar algunas semanas meses pero ya al
menos manifestando la voluntad concreta
y cumpliendo con el compromiso que
habían hecho públicamente de
sumarse a un nuevo proceso constituyente
oa la continuación de este proceso que
terminó el domingo ahora qué garantías
hay de que pueda mejorar la percepción
de la nueva propuesta de constitución
y tú dices la percepción a nivel de
opinión pública del electorado a nivel
en el electorado y también con las
fuerzas políticas del país
bueno hay la verdad que partamos para el
tema de las fuerzas políticas del país
hay que entender el contexto en que
surge este proceso constituyente en el
marco de una crisis de representación
profunda lo que conocemos como el
estadio social de octubre del 2019 en
que
se
básicamente se llama a la generación de
un proceso constituyente en que no
estaban incluidos los partidos políticos
en la conformación de la convención
constitucional
para hacer más clara en el fondo la
crisis de representación se expresaba en
una desafección de la ciudadanía
respecto de los partidos políticos en el
país entonces al convocar a hasta este
el proceso constituyente y al definir
cierto cuál podría ser el órgano que
escribiera la constitución se plantea la
opción de la inclusión de independientes
ya fueran como candidatos únicos o como
listas independientes eso significó y la
representación de los independientes
la convención constitucional en los
convencionales constituyentes era muy
amplia y la de los partidos políticos
era muy baja lo que no reflejó en
realidad la realidad del sistema
político electoral chileno ejerció parte
de la explicación de la votación que se
obtuvo entonces en ese sentido claro
cambia el proceso porque ahora parte de
una mesa de negociación
con los referentes políticos incluidos
va habrá que ver entonces cómo se
incluyen también los movimientos
sociales que fueron parte del proceso
inicial no ahora en términos de opinión
pública eso estará por verse todavía no
sabemos por qué la gente votó rechazo
aunque hay algunas hipótesis pero
claramente por el contenido por una
disconformidad con el contenido entonces
habrá que ver qué surge de este nuevo
proceso para ver qué opina la ciudadanía
en la opción de respaldarlo o no